Robert is in Salt Lake City hey Robert
how are ya hey David how you doing
better than I deserve what's up well my
wife and I were I'm twenty two she's 21
we've got two kids and we've recently
decided after making a bunch of mistakes
while younger to get out of that so I
started listening to you with a
recommendation from my dad and the one
one big question I have you know we're
sitting about all in all with school
loans and everything else medical credit
cards we're sitting probably about
seventy thousand right now that we're
trying to get paid back now that we've
started it's like all the problems start
to come out more as soon as we start
going to set money aside of course we
get hit with the wave
how do you recommend going about trying
to resolve that trying to keep putting
money in the right areas for example I
just put four thousand dollar repair
into my car luckily I didn't have to
take out a loan my grandmother actually
fronted the money for it but now I owe
her that money and it just added it sort
of taken away okay look let's just stop
and think what you just said I didn't
have to take out a loan but now I owe
her money that's kind of like a loan
okay yeah so let's just change our words
and be in full admission of everything
that's going on here all right so what's
your household income about sixty two
thousand and how much do you owe on your
cars my one car outside I owe thousands
of repairs on mine my wife is about five
thousand dollars left to the bank mmm
okay good so what's the bulk of the
seventy thousand what's the big number
student loans student loans about I
probably say about forty three thousand
and student loans
okay your wife at home full-time with
the babies no she works full-time so do
I okay all right what do you make I make
roughly thirty six thousand before
overtime what do you do
I run a computer repair shop that sure
water not very
accounting actually okay you have your
masters no I went to the wrong school
maker that's one of the wrong decisions
I'm just about to graduate with my
associate oh we on Associates in
accounting okay all right cool
all right so here's what we're gonna do
the first thing is is that all these
things coming at you we're coming at you
anyway but now that you decide to pay
attention they're more noticeable and
some of them come at you it's just kind
of the law of we used to laugh and say
if you join Financial Peace University
your transmission goes on in your car
the next week I mean it's like it's just
as if the devil does not want you to win
and he's going to beat up on something
that you own you know and that's kind of
what you got going here so I see a
couple of things one is we've got to get
you on a detailed plan called a budget
and you and your wife totally focused on
that two is we're gonna sell so much
stuff the kids think their next three is
we're gonna see what we can do to get
both of your incomes up temporarily it's
called the dreaded part-time job or
extra overtime or whatever as a
temporary measure you're gonna work like
no one else so later you can work like
no one else because here's the deal a
thirty thousand dollar change in your
household income changes your world
dramatically dramatically and that's
both of you picking up some overtime or
both of you picking up part-time jobs or
whatever okay I don't know how that
works exactly but you're gonna figure it
out people always do and we're gonna
stop borrowing money for anything from
anyone ever including grandmother so I
want you to go through our nine week
class called Financial Peace University
and I'm also going to give you because
when you buy Financial Peace University
of the nine week class you get given the
financial peace membership which is all
of the class online the follow up
classes online on how to teach your kids
online as well as every dollar plus and
the whole thing online so Financial
Peace University and the one-year
membership to financial peace free gonna
give it all to you but you have to
promise you and your wife to go to the
class
and we're gonna get you on a track and
then you're gonna bust it you call me if
you need more help you can do this